welcome to the second set of a present
of the presentations on aged word
problems you have one typed out here
let's see what it says let's say Salman
that's me is a hundred and eight years
old and so this is clearly at some vast
time in the future and and this will
only happen if if my caloric restriction
works out but Salman is 108 years old
Jonathan is 24 years old how many years
will it take for Salman to be exactly
four times as old as Jonathan well let's
figure this one out well what we're
trying to solve for is how many years
will it take so let's use the variable Y
for years
so y equals years until let's just say
Sal for short Sal is four times
Jonathan's
age okay well if today I or Sal is is a
if if Salman it's hard to speak in the
third person if Salman is 100 years old
today in Y years Salman will be 108 plus
y is equal to Sal in Y years I'm saying
Y years now why Sal and Y years is going
to be 108 plus y and then Jonathan and Y
years that's pretty easy he's going to
be 24 plus y so that's John say John for
short in Y years not ears my ears and
what else does the problem say it says
and how many years will it take for
Salman to be exactly let me put that
another color for emphasis exactly four
times as old as Jonathan well and
exactly is important because Salman is
already more than four times as old as
Jonathan but they want to figure out
exactly when is he going to is someone
going to be four
our times as old as Jonathan well in Y
years Salman is going to be 108 plus y
so we know that 108 plus y and after Y
years he's going to be four times as old
as Jonathan exactly four times and
Jonathan's going to be 24 plus Y years
old and now we just solve the equation
we get 108 plus y is equal to four times
24 well 4 times 25 is 100 and then we
can subtract 4 from there so it's 96
plus 4y and now we just solve this
equation we get 3 3 I'm going to skip
some steps because I think these this
part is easy for you 3 y will equal 108
minus 96 so we get 3y is equal to was
that 12 right yeah so Y is equal to 4 so
our algebra has told us that in 4 years
Salman is going to be exactly 4 times as
old as Jonathan let's see if that's true
well so modest 108 right now in 4 years
he's going to be 112 and if Jonathan is
24 right now in 4 years he's going to be
28 and let's see 28 times 4 is 80 plus
32 yep exactly it'll be 100 in 12 so it
looks like that problem worked excellent
let's do another one
hope you didn't hear that that was my
stomach growling see how hard I work on
this site I don't even eat properly ok
let's do another problem and I'll type
it in green this time
the Roush is five times as old as Armand
is today 85 years ago we're dealing with
huge swathes of time 85 years ago the
Roush was 10 times as old as Armand how
old is Armand today let's see if we can
tackle this quite interesting problem I
think let me do my settings put the pen
tool on okay well I think this might be
useful do one of those charts like we
did in the in the first video
presentation well we're trying to solve
for how old is Arman today so let's say
Arman and we're going to have today and
we're going to have what's the other
time period we're dealing with we're
dealing with 85 years ago so let's say
85 years ago a galaxy far far away
okay Arman and the roush well we're
trying to solve for how old is Arman
today so let's just make that X for
simplicity
it says the roush is five times as old
as Arman today so let me underline that
the roush it's five times as old as
Arman today well if Arman is X well that
tells us that the roush is going to be
5x 85 years ago so 85 years ago well if
Arman is X today then 85 years ago Arman
would have been X minus 85 and if the
roush is 5x today then through SH would
be 5x minus 85 I just subtracted 5x from
the car I just effected 85 from their
current
because we're going 85 years in the past
and now we have this extra piece of
information which tells us that 85 years
ago the Roush was 10 times as old as
Armand so this number is going to be 10
times more than this number that's what
that sentence L is 85 years ago we're in
this situation the Roush which is this
was 10 times older than Armand so we
just write that out as algebraically 85
years ago da Rouge is 5x minus 85 and
the sentence tells us that he was 10
times older than Arman who was X minus
85 now we just solved the equation you
get 5x minus 85 is equal to 10x minus
850 and then you get and I'm going to do
this skip some steps just to confuse you
5x is equal to how do I think I just
confused myself 5x is equal to 850 minus
85 let's see what's 850 minus 85 well
it'd be 35 less than 800 so we could say
that 5x thirty-five less than 830 less
than 800 is seven 70s would be 765 and
then X is equal to let me see 5 goes
into 70 one time one times 526 5 times 5
times 5 is 25 15 so X is equal to 153
well we have some long lifespan people
so we get the solution that Arman is a
hundred and fifty three years old today
let's see if that makes sense
well if he's 153 then no no that
and be right because then he's five huh
well actually I'm almost out of time let
me see where I might have messed up on
this
if Arman is X the roush is 5x that makes
sense
oh right right right I think this could
make sense if I just I thought that
Arman had to be that the roush had to be
younger than Arman but no there was five
times one hundred and fifty three so the
Rouge is actually seven hundred and
sixty five years old we should call him
Methuselah
so the Rouge is seven hundred and
sixty-five years old and then if we go
eighty-five years into the past
the Roush would have been what did we
say if if we go 85 years into the past
let's write this down this is equal to
I'm about to run out of time so you
might have to check this yourself
if that's equal to 153 then 5x is equal
to 765 these numbers are big and then
153 - 85 153 155 - 85 would be 70 so
this would be 72 right and then the
Roush 85 years ago no I think I messed
up someplace the Roush Yuna
well actually I only have 10 seconds
before YouTube will let me to upload it
so we'll have to stop there thank you